do you believe we're still causing us
here's how it goes in australia i am
god forbid you die tomorrow morning i
don't know your wife i just met him
maybe once if somebody ever heard her
i'm out of their life
they would have a [ __ ] problem with
me
because i feel um
every fiber of my body feels it and goes
in austria means that your wife
is my sister-in-law if you're my brother
yes your children are my nieces and
nephews i could be in a joint i see your
daughter god forbid in a joint when
somebody's giving that static
i will stick my [ __ ] two cents right
in it
that's close enough that's the good part
of cousin australia well that's that's
the good part and that's the part that's
still stuck in me there's a lot of good
parts that are stuck to me now do i want
to kill anybody no
that's behind me it's ugly it's [ __ ]
up i agree with you there's a lot of
[ __ ] up things they did killing
different people and carmine i was with
him i did a bunch of [ __ ] videos on
him already
killing [ __ ] women and people and
people's kids that
wasn't necessary it happens we talked
about roy the mayo it happens
we get rid of him
that's why he was called the [ __ ]
snake now i don't i was with him i liked
him when i was with him it was tough it
was everything i liked at that point in
my life i look back at him now
not too happy with him
but there was a lot a lot of good people
in the life
and abided by the life
you